the Queen arrived at church in Norfolk
with Prince Andrew another member of the
family who hasn't given her an easy time
but it's the deal that she's done with
her grandson's that's continuing to rock
the royal family in a statement she
confirmed that she was letting Harry and
Megan begin their new life after
negotiations within the palace and
Whitehall but speaking from his home in
Mexico Megan's own father was far from
supportive of his daughter's decision he
actually got every girl's dream every
young girl wanted to become a princess
and she got that and now she's tossing
that away for it looks like she thought
secretly for money the intense interest
in her relationship with her dad has
been a big part of the media scrutiny
the couple are desperate to escape I
understood the media might be interested
in what I did
strikingly similar to the reasons his
mother gave for stepping back in 1993
but I was not aware of how overwhelming
that attention would become like Diana
back then it's not entirely clear what
life is going to be like for Harry and
his family away from the protection of
Palace life the fact that we've been
told that these plans could be reviewed
in a year's time says a lot about the
discussions that still need to go on
behind the scenes to work out how this
is practically going to pan out they may
no longer be working Royals but they
will still be important members of the
family and that means the scrutiny
around everything they do is not going
to stop and that means the lucrative
business deals they make and the jobs
they decide to take as well as any hint
that they may be trying to overshadow
other members of the family precisely
what the Queen has been trying to avoid
by getting this deal done fast it's
difficult because the monarchy isn't
just a family it's a business and two of
its major shareholders have decided to
break free and basically set up a rival
company in North America
the sixes had given the Queen there
their notice and this was the 93 year
old Manik basically giving them their
p45 when they got engaged this was a
couple excited about what they could
achieve together this beautiful woman
just sort of literally tripped and fell
into my life I spun into her life and
the fact that she I know the fact that
she'll be really unbelievably good at
their job part of it as well it's
obviously huge relief to me because
she'll be able to deal with with
everything else that comes with it but
[Applause]
it hasn't been the fairy tale we'd all
built it up to be in this next chapter
there was no chance of being part-time
Royals as sacrifice they're prepared to
make their dream of a peaceful new
family life